is pumpkin carving weather although
after a high only in the 70s yesterday
we're going to be back into the 80s
today and tomorrow it is a little bit of
that temperature rolling coaster
again a lot of storm clouds yesterday
didn't amount to much of anything in
terms of officially there was a trace of
rain at mccarran a couple of
neighborhoods really did get dumped on
briefly so here's a live look at our
camera on the red rock resort looking
out to the east sunrise more than an
hour about an hour and a half away from
now officially we're hanging at 64. but
temperatures are for sure dropping under
what's becoming a mostly clear sky how
about 58 down in seven hills and anthem
59 mountains edge rhodes ranch aliante
you're at 59. wind is not a factor
lingering cloud cover is quickly pushing
out to the east so we go to nevada and
beyond maybe a lingering sprinkle for
cedar city you're at 51 52 right now for
kingman we'll show you this area of low
pressure as it pushes out to the east
over the hump improv you are at 59 good
morning to beatty with your 51 tonopah
cooling down to the 40s although ely at
45 that's relatively balmy compared with
readings that had been in the 20s so we
mentioned 78 for yesterday's high first
time we've been in the 70s since may but
back to 84 today we'll be in the 80s
again tomorrow so this area of low
pressure pushing out to the east maybe
some lingering storms for lincoln county
and southwestern utah but the next
system is on its way we'll be getting a
lot more clouds during the day today an
area of low pressure also over parts of
the deep south here is your 8 day
forecast after 84 today we'll be up to
85 tomorrow but clouds take over and the
breezes begin to build it is going to be
downright windy on friday gusts maybe to
30 miles an hour and the high
temperature hello
oh there it is 76 for friday 77 for
saturday
78 for sunday and another system could
drop temps into the 60s next week